الصباح الباكر هو بالتأكيد أفضل
وقت للتواجد على الشاطئ على طول ساحل كوستا
ديل سول ، تلك الأميال السحرية من الشمس
والبحر بين ملقة وماربيلا ، لقد
كنت قادمًا هنا لقضاء عطلة منذ أن كنت
في ارتفاع الركبة إلى
جندب لقد رأيته  كل شيء ولكني لم
أفهم حقًا ما يدور حوله إلى جانب
مذهب المتعة في إجازة لمدة أسبوعين
[موسيقى]
ابتسمت ثروة أنا هنا في نفس
الوقت مع أختي التوأم كارولين
عندما يمكننا أن نتذكر تلك
الأيام المجنونة الكسولة  فصول الصيف الشبابية التي أمضيتها
هنا
مألوفة مثل فرانكارولا ، شعرت أختي بأنني
اقترحت أن أزور ميها قرية صغيرة على
جانب التل بالكاد تبعد 20 كيلومترًا
عن شقتنا ، وأشعر بالحرج من القول في
مكان ما لم أزره أبدًا ،
إنه مكان مثالي
لبدء جهلي بالذهاب
هناك  هي حديقة مخفية حيث يمكنني
اجترار الحياة محتمًا من
الحرارة الشديدة ،
فأنت في ورشة العمل المثالية التي تعرفها
لأن هذه مقدمة لتقنية
الميوليكا المصنوعة من خزف زجاجي.
حسنًا ، عادةً ما يكون طلاء أبيض
وطلاء من الأعلى بالأصباغ
والأكاسيد ، يبدو الأمر بسيطًا للغاية ،
فنحن نحاول أن نجعل الأمر بسيطًا
من شفاه كارمن إلى يدي ،
أوه إنها كارثة لا ، انظر جيدًا
هناك كرة أرضية كبيرة هناك
القليل منها مفقود  هنا ،
تم تصميم ورشة الرسم بالبطاقات البريدية هذه
كوسيلة مريحة لالتقاط القليل من
سحر ميخا الإسبانية ثم إرسالها إلى المنزل ،
لست متأكدًا من أن أي شخص سيرحب برسوم
طوابي المصورة التي
كانت والدتي فنانة
ولا يمكنني رسم اثنين لاحقًا
يقود تشجيع كارمن المهدئ
الطريق
حتى مع مهاراتي المحدودة ،
يبدو أن السحر يعمل ،
سيتحول هذا إلى سلسلة فان جوخ
وعباد الشمس مونيه وزنابقه ، كان هذا
هو السعي وأوانيه
وكان هذا هو أول
دعوة للأواني  من الوهم أو الاكتشاف الذاتي ،
ربما ضرب الشمس
اكتشافي في هذه الزيارة إلى ميخاس هو بالفعل ملاذ رائع من
روتيني المعتاد لكوستا ديل سول
[موسيقى]